hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde ich habe das schild dort
hinten verändert da steht jetzt nicht
mehr wer das süße stoff sondern wer das
liest stinkt ich hoffe es gefällt euch
herzlich willkommen wir heute auf jeden
fall zu einem neuen video auf meinem
kanal meine lieben freunde keine ahnung
wir euch jeden fall ihr habt aber es
freut mich irre wir machen nämlich heute
gemeinsam eine tried to get the
challenge ii regeln sind erstens dauert
in the commons und zweitens it yourself
beim zweiten kann ich noch nicht so ganz
zustimmen aber ich würde sagen wir
schauen erst mal das video an let's go
steht hier level 1 creepy forthaus
[Musik]
also wir haben in dem video erscheint
verschiedene level zu nehmen ich mein
genauer betrachtet ist es wahrscheinlich
einfach ein mensch mit glatze
[Musik]
ich kann bei so was gar nicht hin
spätestens nach diesem bild hier weiß
ich dass dieses video hier definitiv
nicht werbe freundlich sein
das ist einfach das ist einfach ein face
webfilter bei und sie hat dann das
gesicht von der puppe und ziert das
gesicht von der mutter ja gibt da noch
angenehmere bilder die man sich
anschauen kann dass wir heute wird es ab
18 sein okay das geht jetzt einigermaßen
nochmals wird aber auf jeden fall das
heutige video wird safe ab 18 sein und
auch nicht werbe freundlich sein
wir kommen auch schon zum level 2 gibt's
hier
[Musik]
und noch was sie da
ich will alle unter euch mich schon ein
bisschen länger kennen wissen dass ich
der absolute horror hayta bin ich kann
mir keine horrorfilme anschaulich aber
gewirkt wie in einem horrorfilm war das
war absolutes chaos ich aber für sehr
ausländer gespielt jedes video davon hat
irgendwie glaub ich über eine million
aufrufe weil ich mich immer so krass
erschrocken habe deswegen komme ich
nicht klar wenn ich irgendwie sowas sehe
aber machen wir weiter mit dem letzten
level und zwei levels wie videos
also das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt dass
man sich erschreckt aber sei
einfach creepy es fakt
wie im doppel zusammen
ok sie soll jetzt da im raum bleiben ich
hätte ein bisschen selbst ratings gerade
sie packt jetzt hier den
vorsicht mit dem nächsten video hier
dann ist ein polizist und der typ 356
vor dem polizisten keine ahnung was sie
dann irgendwie vorsichtig sind gar
nichts war zweifellos ist erhält jetzt
gegen diana baden gerade warum ist das
jetzt her das macht überhaupt keinen
sinn okay ist es anscheinend nur eine
wand
was tue ich hier also da ist jetzt
plötzlich im gegenteil skins das steht
die kamera schaut rum ich mir machts
halt am meisten angst hat das ganze halt
in echt irgendwie das kann auch nicht
de facto gekriegt weil dieses video an
das er durch das heutige wird jetzt
allerdings auf jeden fall auch beenden
meine lieben freunde ganz viele von euch
haben ihr letztes unter meinem nicht
lachen challenge geschrieben dass sich
auch mal das gegenteil machen soll also
ein kleiner trick jetzt gerd challenge
von der hier heute das video ich glaube
dass videos nicht mehr freundlich glaube
auch es ist ab 18 also ich weiß ja dass
jeder von euch sehen konnte kommen aber
gerne in die kommentare schreiben was
ich nächste woche für eine challenge
machen soll
viele meinten auch eine trainer
challandes aber ich singe eni und ich
kann nicht singen von daher macht das
eigentlich nicht so viel sinn aber
schreibt man auf jeden fall gern
vorschläge und in die kommentare last
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
damit euch diesen trailer zu dirt
challenge gefallen hat und noch mal ganz
kurz sagen keine story dass meine stimme
heute werden ein bisschen heiser ist und
das heutige video auch ein bisschen
kürzer ist aber ich bin erkältet und
hatte mich mit 800 millionen
medikamenten vollgestopft dass ich hier
so gerade stehen kann
abonieren einen kanal und ich bin jetzt
wieder im bett trinken
[Musik]